et tout d'abord donc le drame du petit
yliès il à partir de 83 à l'âge de 7 ans
il y avait été traité pour grandir
on lui injecter les hormones de
croissance jusqu'en 88 ces hormones
étaient prélevées sur des cadavres
après on a utilisé les hormones de
synthèse qui ne sont pas dangereuses
melia s'il a eu le malheur d'être
contaminé par une maladie très rare la
maladie de creutzfeldt jakob
il n'a pas été le seul d'ailleurs et il
est mort fin 91 sa famille avaient
décidé plusieurs mois auparavant de
porter plainte c'est cette plainte qui
vient d'aboutir à la mise en examen des
professeurs job et dre valérie gas et
alexis marant témoignages l'album d'une
vie trop vite refermée celle d'il ya six
morts en 91 à l'âge de 15 ans victime
d'un retard de croissance
le jeune garçon avait été traité d 83
avec une hormone d'origine humaine
diffusé par l'association france
hypophyse ses parents ont ensuite
constaté que sa santé se dégrader en
septembre 89 il a commencé à avoir des
maux de tête ont des visions et puis des
tremblements c'est à cette époque lac
dont j'ai contacté l'hôpital necker où
on l'a emmenée on lui a fait des examens
dont le scanner l'irm
l'électroencéphalogramme bon il y avait
rien tout est normal
poussé par une intuition les parents
d'ilyas il décide alors deux même
d'arrêter les injections d'hormones mais
il est trop tard
à cause d'elle leur fils a contracté la
maladie de creutzfeldt jakob
une lésion rares mortels il porte
plainte d'abord pour blessures
involontaires puis après la mort de leur
fils pour homicide involontaire
je suis dit il faut ya faute il faut
chercher la vérité
le but de votre plainte c'est quoi c'est
chercher la vérité les voir j'espère
condamné à être condamné ces faits ces
gens là
et on a pas mal de personnes qui sont
derrière tout ça pour l'avocate de la
famille la sphère présente des
similitudes avec celle du sang contaminé
même si elle touche un nombre de
personnes plus restreint mais nous avons
la certitude que les médecins
connaissait les risques
dès 1981 de de contamination de
l'hormone de croissance et car aucun
moment nous avons avisé les parents rien
ne permet pour l'instant d'établir que
de graves négligences ont été commises
avec d'autres familles de victimes
les parents d'ilyas ils attendent les
conclusions de l'enquêté